one of the like most like
relatable things on the on the first
season of the show that i
i was like this is so spot on was the yg
feature part oh yeah shout out to homie
yg man that [ __ ] happens
so often in hip hop where you'll you'll
cash someone out for a feature it's
probably not going to get cleared
by the major label they're never going
to push it or reply they're never going
to push it they're never going to repost
it and it is going to be
a [ __ ] mission to actually get the
stems and the verse and
that was like the most like i was like
this is some real ass [ __ ] right the
whole the whole show was so real like
it's just like coming up as like a
artist like but like that specific was
that like something that actually
happened
like something similar to that that
actually happened yeah definitely cuz i
know he cashed out kwon and he cashed
out fetty for that song because i
remember he told me
yeah definitely man stuff didn't happen
to a lot of artists in the game you know
what i'm saying
gucci ran off on french with five
thousand you know what i'm saying
he uh he has french but something like
that happened to dickie where it was
like like he like he cashed somebody out
it was like a little bit harder to get
get
i think so but i don't know like the
exact details but
it'd be a lot of stuff going on behind
the scenes you know and
you got to deal with a lot of the stuff
when you're on this path because
everybody know that music industry
is like street spread it's kind of it
kind of is man
i'm saying a lot of janky stuff going on
were you uh how instrument
are you as far as just like bringing
ideas to the table for the tv show
i'm a consultant on there if you read
the credits at the end and say gator
actor gated consultant like
i chime in i go to the writer sessions
they ask me certain scenarios how i was
saying because it was so authentic
it was it just felt like so like i never
say what's on the paper man in the
script i always go off i got the green
light to do that from
fx and from dave it's like it's like it
does a really good job of like the show
is
if you have nothing like no knowledge of
the music industry and you're just
watching a comedy it's [ __ ] hilarious
but if you know you know [ __ ]
it's like oh this is like spot on like
this is how it is
i just like that we got jokes for both
audiences you know i'm saying 100
black people we got that you know i'm
saying for the white people we got that
you know what i'm saying we bring it
together that's what i really like you
know we got the best of both worlds